so many shows are revamping reboosts
when are we gonna get up in my ride no
no there'll be no more pin my eyes hmm
[Music]
but your wheels ain't fly you gotta hit
us up to get them camped out ride
[Music]
you ready for the street yo you need
these your freshly been felt all right
are there any fond memories that you
have what was the craziest episode that
you had to shoot which ride was crazy
you know the thing about pimp my ride is
we had a lot of fun doing it and nobody
knew that show was gonna be what it was
we changed lives we made people think
that this could happen to them and I
think that's the magic of it it wasn't
about me it wasn't about the car it
wasn't even about the show is about wish
fulfillment and I think that's what I
miss about it this car will benefit me a
lot of ways people would take me serious
you laughing me anymore
I could keep all the girls but exhibit
told et at HBO's the Defiant ones
premiere he would like to get back in
the studio with a few music legends
bring it a collab between you dr. Dre
and Eminem I mean can we get another one
when will that happen well I mean that's
up to them I mean I'm down for it any
time but I'm looking forward to it but I
really know whatever dr. Dre puts his
thought my my impressive modern process
to and whatever Jimmy Iovine gets
involved with it becomes magic